the cal iso has started rotating power
outages governor newsome today addressed
the recent rolling blackouts we failed
to predict
energy conservation is what the
california independent system operator
wants to see has the confirmation the
overall picture
is that the california grid ran out of
energy
critics say california's rolling
blackouts this summer were caused by
decades of costly and poorly planned
decisions to replace
coal nuclear and gas-powered plants with
solar and wind
speaks to the delusion of california
policy makers they
really convince themselves that they
could manage
all of this increased demand on
renewables which are fundamentally
unreliable
michael schellenberger is the president
of environmental progress
which advocates for greater reliance on
nuclear power as a way to reduce co2
emissions and provide
reliable energy california banned the
construction of new nuclear reactors
in 1976 and has been incentivizing
companies to close older plants
by piling on burdensome regulations ever
since
schellenberger says this loss has made
california more susceptible to blackouts
we were looking at about a 4 000
megawatt shortfall the two nuclear
plants the one that shut down the one
they want to shut down total
4 400 megawatts so it would have just
provided the energy that we
didn't have the other thing is that the
nuclear plant unlike the solar
farms or the wind is reliable like 92
percent of the year
the only times you can't have it is when
you're adding new fuel to the plant
policy makers also started closing down
natural gas plants because they produce
more co2 emissions than wind and solar
ignoring warnings that doing so would
lead to shortages
and governor gavin newsom recently
signed an executive order
asking the state legislature to ban
fracking for oil and gas
but the problem with wind and solar is
that they only provide consistent energy
under optimal weather conditions and
they just shut down too many of them
there's a lot of fancy dancing to
explain how it wasn't a result of
renewables
but it was fundamentally that the sun
goes down
at the exact moment that peak demand
starts to climb
but a major operator of california's
grid says that it wasn't
renewables like wind and solar that
caused the blackouts
but a lack of easily accessible backup
energy
renewables have not caused this issue
this is a resource issue not a renewable
issue some defenders of renewable energy
even say that fossil fuels are the real
culprit
and that critics like schellenberger are
distorting the facts
in service of their preconceived biases
the august blackout they point out
was directly caused by the failure of a
natural gas
generator those fossil fuel technologies
have trouble performing in the heat
in fact solar generation doesn't have
trouble performing in the heat
energy analyst amol fadki is the
co-author of uc berkeley's 2035 report
which argues that america should
transition to 90
carbon-free energy generation in the
next 15 years
but the natural gas generator that
failed was a backup system
which flipped on only because the
state's energy capacity
failed as californians blasted their air
conditioners to deal with a heat wave as
the sun went down
and the wind slowed those had to come
online because they are the backup for
the renewables that those were kind of
planned generation
okay the way you plan the power system
is that you
know the sun is gonna set fadgi says a
failure to adequately plan
backup power was the real problem and in
fact
i would argue that having lot more
renewable energy
will make the and storage will make the
grid even more robust
as california has increased its reliance
on renewable energy
it has also become increasingly reliant
on energy imported from neighboring
states
they're counting on their neighbors too
much and those neighbors need their
power plants
because they're hot too engineer and
investor mark mills
is a faculty fellow at northwestern
university and a senior fellow at the
manhattan institute
he says that california's push to
replace traditional power plants with
renewables has created a shortage of
what's known as
dispatchable capacity or generators that
can be
flipped on when there's a spike in
demand what would happen in a normal
grid is another gas turbine
would fire up and there'd be no blackout
what happened in the first blackouts is
that they didn't have dispatchable
capacity
and worse than that there was a wind
lull so it's simultaneous to the gas
turbine not coming online and then you
have to force
blackouts to keep the rest of the grid
lit none of that would have happened
if you're losing conventional capacity
and the more wind you add the less
disposable you have
the more likely you'll have those events
occur because you'll have fewer and
fewer dispatchable assets
just it's simple logic fatkey says the
solution is for california to build
even more solar power plants and invest
more money in giant batteries that can
store power from the wind and sun
during off hours in the long run if you
have enough batteries to transfer that
solar energy during the day
into the evening hours you are good and
the good news is that the cost of those
batteries has dropped by 90 percent
since 2010 the
constant babbling about batteries is an
embarrassing failure to understand
arithmetic
mills has calculated that storing a
barrel of oils worth of energy in a
battery
costs at least a hundred times as much
and that it would take
about a thousand years for the world's
largest battery factory
to produce enough to store two days
worth of america's energy needs
batteries are never going to get cheaper
to store energy than storing oil in a
barrel
until we develop a room temperature
superconductor which doesn't exist
could exist in theory and it could
become cheap in theory sometimes
if that ever happens we can store
electricity as cheap as oil in a barrel
changes the world mills also points out
that the intensive mining
required to produce batteries has a
major environmental cost
wind and solar are very diffuse energy
sources so the amount of land required
is order magnitude 10 to 30 times more
than for hydrocarbons
because you're diffuse energy sources
you have to build lots of machines
when you build lots of machines you have
to mine more stuff america doesn't like
mines anymore so we depend on mines as
most people by now know
cobalt half of its mind in democratic
republic congo chinese mind that rare
earths
we don't anymore the biggest nickel
mines in the world are in the arctic
russia australia does a lot of the
mining for the world we can mine more
but the increase in mining that the
green energy path
will require will be the biggest
increase in mineral extraction the world
has ever seen
instead of producing our own oil and gas
and energy which is 80
of our energy we will import energy
minerals from somebody else that will
increase imports increase strategic
dependencies increase
deficits you may think that's fine but
it's a real cost that no one's counting
it's dishonest but the 2035 report
estimates the cost of not quickly
pivoting to renewables
at 1.2 trillion dollars in health and
environmental damages
and 85 000 premature deaths by 2050. it
recommends a combination of emission
standards
government subsidies and tax incentives
to ramp up solar wind and battery
production
as quickly as possible why not just say
we're gonna
set a standard and then however you get
there
figure that out rather than tipping the
scale towards
solar and wind yeah i think that's the
first best option
i would say that i think the simplest
option but which is not politically
acceptable is tax the polluters i mean
you have to pay
your fair share of what damage you do
but schellenberger says that nuclear
would provide the clean and abundant
energy that
both sides want if only california and
other states would stop
creating incentives for them to close
down and allow new ones to open up
just keeping the nuclear plants online
would have kept prices down
significantly if california had a vision
of being like france
75 nuclear getting our cooking and
heating
from electricity well that could be a
very good deal for both consumers and
the natural environment but nobody's
talking about that
and mill says that ironically the
technological innovations that would be
required to fulfill the
environmentalists dreams
rely on continuing to have abundant
energy
right now if you want to go from
propellers to jet engines
if you want to go from combustion to
nuclear fission if you want those kind
of phenomenology changes if you want to
store electricity as cheap as we store
oil
you need a different whole new solution
because we always have new discoveries
but they don't come from directed
development where
government says make that wind turbine
better build me more wind turbines to
get the kinds of shifts that people are
talking about in society to get
something
as profound as discovering of nuclear
fission takes discoveries
in basic science so you produce energy
at the least
possible cost to have as much profit to
invest in basic science
and invest in adaptation and resilience
there's a respectable chance a lot of
america will
follow in uh california's path i think
that's the path we're on
this is what their plan is so if you are
concerned about the blackouts
the six-fold increase in electricity
prices
the bad management of our electrical
grid that causes fires in places where
we should have less fires not more
then yeah you should be concerned about
what's happening in california and not
want it to be imposed on the rest of the
[Music]
u.s